à quand on fait ce stream en direct et
c'est donc la soirée pour le tournoi
mensuel bitstream
c'est une habitude maintenant à ce
tournant est toujours les premiers
jeudis du mois et on parlera de
l'arrivée du nouveau tournant fonds va
parler directement
tous les vendredis 20h30 sur le club
jazz comme français donc je vais mettre
tous les liens petit à petit mais je
vais attendre que les gens arrivent et
au cas où vous regardez ça en replay je
mettrai le lien dans la description
faite donc où en sommes nous en sommes
nous bien on a du coup le tournant est
lancée alors j'imagine qu'il ya déjà des
gens dans le chat minidou kevin comment
y participer
on va voir on va voir ça va arriver dans
l'ocha de toute façon cette question
cette question va obligatoirement
arrivée dans le tchat un jour ou l'autre
donc je m'y attends j'ai juste ouvrir
tous les tchats et je me faire quelques
bulles est histoire de histoire de quoi
histoire de se faire plus le bullet ça
fait plein non pas ça va tu peux pas je
peux pas me permettre de jouer au blitz
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi c'est
que mardi il ya la qualif pour le
comment s'appelle la qualif pour le
speech est championship et pour pouvoir
y participer faut être plus de 2500 sur
sur chaque point comme et donc c'est
plus de 2700 500 sur chaise points comme
on les a et j'ai pas du tout envie de
les perdre parce que je les ai gagnées
pendant pendant l'arrêt n'a donc cessé
classement bis 3 minutes on va pas se
prendre la tête en juin du 3 minutes en
prenant le risque de perdre le
classement donc on va se faire on va se
faire quelques petits bullet hell arena
on a pour le moment que quatre
participants mais bon faut que les gens
arrivent il est 20 heures 2 les gens ont
petit à petit petit à petit vont venir
moi je vais essayer de mettre 2 3 pls en
bullet la vie de fait et après j'imagine
que j'aurai toutes les questions du chat
qui me tombe dessus
donc on sera bon je vais vérifier aussi
que qu'on arrive sur deux choses comme
tv on va se lancer dans le bullet
on va essayer de les remettre quelques
petites perez quand même maintenant je
veux pas je veux pas participer au
tournoi
non je peux participer à l'aréna je veux
plus partir de l'aréna manon bon non
mais je ne veux pas jouer à red hat je
regardais les parties mais je pense que
je pourrais je pourrais me débrouiller
pour quitter jour et que la première
partie du coût mais ok mais je veux
jouer des bulles est en fait allé boum
boum
voilà déjà les huit déjà il en perez de
base
allez on va lui faire mal
pas trop dans l'esprit pour le moment on
n'a rien sacrifié encore allez vas y
prends le fou les fous ne m'intéresse
pas a dit bouffe
alors va te prendre ton cavaliers tu
aimerais te donner les deux fous pas les
tiens ces concepts on donne les fous
quoi on s'en fout très intéressante mais
cavale ils sont très bien placés
maintenant on va être le cavalier à m6
alors on va jouer à trois on va jouer un
peu solide et on va lui mettre le cadre
d'une enquête on va la jouer dans
l'esprit dans certains esprits un peu
différent c'est un esprit finale ah
tiens une dame en est désolé les mecs
enfin je ne voulais pas quoi je ne
voulais pas lui prendre le jeu n'est pas
fait exprès quoi le beau jeu c'est quoi
ras le bol je sais durant de la tour
déjà bon ça déjà c'est bien mais vous
êtes on lui rend la dame d'une manière x
ou y
comment on peut faire ça allait on lui
rend la dame pour le plaisir à laisser
le beau jeu on y va on rend la dame
c'est beau et samatan g8 et samatan g8
et voilà les tontons voilà les tontons
ça c'était l'esprit à fond ça c'est ce
qu'on aime ici je mets le téléphone sur
silencieux parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
j'entends des vibrations boum ça vous
voyez c'est pour ça qu'on aime cette
chaîne j'ai envie de te dire tu es en
torrent la dame dégage donc en échange
un peu hâlé boum on prend le centre du
rap adams est avec le petit match qui
fait plaise bon mais le cavalier là on
va mettre le fond c'est simple on a dû
attaquer ici à les allaiter tonton oui
bah c'est pas grave on fait c'est si son
protège dents attention attention le
cavalier arrivant au 4 c'est un tour de
magie
il y est ça ils protègent salah pas pour
longtemps
bon on va ramener vers détroit
boum g5 dégage avec ton cavaliers je ne
veux plus te voir
bon alors là j'ai pas compris
j'ai pas compris
honnêtement je donne tout je vois pas
grand chose ce soir pour le moment
comment ça pue un peu je suis pas super
rapide non plus et voilà on claque le
fou ici à eux quatre ça nous permet de
prendre là on va prendre là il va
prendre là et allez ça fait deux heures
cette histoire car moins qu'on tombe
mais dans l'esprit ça fait deux heures
bon
après mus que par tous
bon je fais n'importe quoi mais je le
fais bien attention
allez c'est gagné il a abandonné allez
revient mais alors qu'est ce qu'il fait
là le tonton à il quitte à y en a marre
on a donné la date on a fait le beau jeu
on a fait le beau jeu de partout mais
bon les mecs on est là on donne des
dames quoi j'en ai beau quoi et voilà
vous prend le pion direct c'est parti
il est là voilà besoin deuxième avec
ayew 5 je récupère du matériel dont il
ya d'amd 5 je reviens en f3 c'est le
beau jeu et ses trois maintenant
s'attaque tadam tu as perdu du temps
boum eu quatre manches s'attaque ton fou
allez je prends la tâche 3 dégage voir
revenir en d1 avec la dame là me de on
est très bien on protège tout tout est
protégé
maintenant on va faire qu'on va faire
quoi maintenant on va faire à 4 va
développer de ce côté là boum
allez on se développe par les côtés un
c'est très bien de ne vous développez
jamais par le centre on développe
toujours par le côté beaucoup plus
intéressant voilà donc là on est en
train de se développer par le côté c'est
un peu le gange cette position mais bon
ils échangent les dames on accepte très
impressionné par notre développement il
se sent obligé d'échanger les dames fois
à troyes en échange tout je vous cache
pas que le tour pro d2 c'est pénible
mais peut-être 3,3 net et 3 3 il est mal
aller là il a il a quoi on en est ou
matériellement
fays pharma t elle à mon avis on n'est
pas passé loin de la correctionnelle
bon allez faut le faire tomber
différents apprend yamadou boum boum tu
t'es fait mater fait très attention
l'esprit et au dessus de toi vous voulez
ce prix au dessus de tout fantastique
allez on lui fait de petits gambie sympa
tu fais un gambit aller boom f5
je suis un chat a fait attention faut
faire très attention de pas se faire
mater direct parce que c'est un peu le
destin normalement normalement sombrer
notre destin quand on joue comme ça mais
mais bon en train de s'en sortir on va
développer un f6 lecavalier hockey des
six on protège tout on est là on est
bien car élèves six avantages noir fait
très attention
ta position déjà pour les tons foutu est
encore floue échec malheureusement
mais mon ouverture était fantastique et
des 5 des cas dégage
on va les sacrifiés comme des brutasses
un boom l'esprit boum boum boum a les
boules ont fait comme ça on n'est plus
dans l'esprit que toi fou prend des six
qui ont prévu trois regarde c'est une
attaque de maths c'est de la magie
thierry mallard france huard ou lâchant
sûr j'ai fait une bêtise avec ma souris
je censure à liverpool après quatre
bouts le petit matin qui fait plaise
ouais c'est l'esprit au dessus de
toulouse des quatre qui n'est qu'un
préambule pour un pour faire de la merde
total h 4 h 5 boom tu joueras pas
toujours à page et six dans cette partie
et maintenant je m'installe l'assuré
total pour notre adversaire il n'en peut
plus alors commandement sueur total on
va prendre là j'ai mal joué pour le
mettre en surgît mal joué j'ai eu des
idées mais n'étaient pas pas n'étaient
pas bonnes excusez moi je m'excuse je
vous demande de m'excuser
là c'est hyper tendu la dame qui
protègent cette diagonale très important
on est de nouveau très mal va se
développer deux côtés
c'est le vrai développement évidemment
on se développe deux côtés c'est très
intéressant on couvre
on est mal autant on est mal de partout
c'était pas assez discret
mais ça ça va ça on en a des jardins qui
est tellement des finales qui ressemble
à ça s'est très mal joué
à
ah yes yes yes avec 0,01 la pls l'apea
laisse aller à chis g5 boom sur total
pour l'adversaire
boom ces cinq je pousse les pions de
partout où vous allez dégage
allez dégage bouffe
vas-y bouffe un peu tout partout tu voir
ce qui va t'arriver fait très attention
à ce que tu fais mal hein c'est très
attention à tes prochains coups bon moi
je ne vais pas au kansas et en été au
courant maintenant on va se mettre là il
va être préparé du cavale prend 2,4
attention je te préviens bon il lévite
pour le moment on va lui donner le
funana branler les fous on a compris ça
sert à rien on en a rien à [ __ ] du fou
en faites pas il a dit viens viens viens
viens attaqué aux sept la diff et on a
là là là là là là encore un échangeur de
dames
il y en a marre quoi il ne pense qu'à ça
je cache mon propre fou fait attention
je reviens la ferrette fait gaffe des
cavaliers qui vont arriver mais va
refaire un échec ok j'en ai absolument
rien à faire je dégage
oui bon ben ça sert à rien ce que tu
viens de faire
hayatou reprendre
mais j'en crois le pion
bon tu as payé pour ton arrogance fait
très attention sur les changes et les
dames tu es puni pour ça qu'il va pas
rejouer à léon jouhaux la boum j'ai
quatre reprises un chat fait très
attention à l'est le fond j'ai deux très
bien placé une nouvelle fois nous sommes
très heureux j'aurais dû faire bande des
quatre
dommage l'espace jeu lattaque elles font
eux cinq fait très attention
comment te prends ta qualité on te fait
autour des 1
on est très heureux quoi petit rock
on reste assez mal mais c'est pas grave
si tu as reprendre le bouton cavaliers
je reviens en des cas demain je vous la
finale va dit là il veut plus être final
6 ok je veux la finale va si bien
montre moi qui prouve moi était plus
fort que moi avait dit je prendre ça on
est ok je te prends là et je meurs avec
mauroy tarifaire tour serge prend la
colonne ouverte
j'ai très attention je monte mon roi
prend un pion mais ça on s'en fout ça va
pas du tout dans l'esprit et maintenant
je t'envoie les pions passé dans la
gueule question de tt plante peut plus
avancer donc je t'attaque mais je pousse
maintenant fait abstrait attention j'ai
un objectif c'est pousser un gevrey a
tout de suite été pion seront plus
avancé fédérateur fait très attention
je savais que tu allais jouer ça donc
automatiquement tu ne m'as pas surpris
mais je vais te faire tomber je suis
tombé comme une merde
bon tu es tu tombé battu n'existe plus
bon alors est-ce qu'on peut l'adopter en
jouant comme ça boubé 5
tu es complètement à la rue d'amos est
je développe madame c'est très
intéressant développement rapide de la
dame
là je me place très intéressant la main
je n'irai plus qu'un hiver des trois ça
te faire très mal
attention ces petits rock adam courage
de maths enfin bref comment ils gagnent
en ont douze coups c'est une question
qu'on se pose donc avec ton cul - enfin
dégage avec ta dam des gages avec ton
pions j'aimerais bien qu'une phase dame
prend mais bon il l'a vu c'était un
piège un peu naïf que j'ai tenté avec
eric à l'échec l'esprit à fond et ont dû
rejouer une finale on le met en pls on
va leur faire tomber c'est génial on ne
joue que pour le flag en fait à je
voulais pas faire ça évidemment bon
c'est pas grave on ne joue que pour le
flag en fait c'est en fait de base on
veut pas jouer deux finales mais le mec
a commencé donc il est puni pour un
nouveau concept en fait c'est le concept
de la punition
on veut te mettre en paix à l'est se
jouer des finales bah tant pis pour toi
c'est bien fait pour ta gueule tu
n'auras plus que des finales maintenant
tu vas tomber dans toutes les parties si
tu n'es pas assez rapide un échec et on
va te prendre comme ça mais maintenant
on va pousser les pions
attention je protège mon pions tu ne
pourras jamais de manger je mange ici je
mets deux pions pas c'est qu'ils sont
très heureux
dégage un tueur un pion de moins
qu'avant je le pousse toi tu n'as plus
rien à faire bae mais bon c'est toi qui
a commencé à jouer des finales intentons
tir il faut aller par un bailleur sais
c'est pas de ma faute
moi je n'y suis pour rien moi je voulais
jouer dans l'esprit voulait faire des
parties marrante a commencé à jouer des
finales battu à deux bouffées que des
finales dans la gueule tu ne dois plus
en gagner une belle main sur un système
de londres c'est fini ne vont plus dans
l'esprit pas mince traduc ou mince on
joue plus dans l'esprit on se trompe
lachance quoi ça va prendre a pas joué
dans l'esprit quand je mets le fond en
g2 ça le fait bien placées ont valu à
récupérer son pion j'ai dit qu'on allait
récupérer le pion va le récupérer enfin
le ma question je vous le dis tout de
suite on à faire un relou ça il va
placer son cavalier de merde en d3 il va
faire chier le monde lui re bouffe les
pièces jeu toronto je te rends ton
matériel
je viens te bouffe et ça c'est hyper
chiant à jouer ça
pour les blancs
oui moi si tu peux échanger les dames en
échange enfin ça n'est pas de souci ça
tu échanges et c'est avec plaisir
fais attention à essayer dès le matin
sa menace rien mais ça fait peur et
maintenant on va lui échanger les tours
pour le faire tomber comme une merde
bah ouais mais bon c'est lui qui a
commencé un c'est lui qui a commencé je
n'y suis pour rien et je suis désolé
mais si vous voulez vous inscrire il ya
la reine ac c'est en cours on est en
train d dont on est en train de tenter
une adoption la main en train de tenter
une adoption donc adoption au courant
c'est toujours plus d'adopter en 2003 où
l'été 2004 à la base nous on va dire
2003 parce qu'il est 2003 maintenant ça
donne tellement vite te sacrifier un
truc en h2 t'imagines même pas comment
je pourrais te prendre là ok non mais
c'est tellement mauvaise que je suis en
train de faire il l'a vu quoi j'ai
tellement espéré qu'ils voient pas
refaire kf3 échec
non vraiment on va pas échanger
toujours pas échangé on protège pour le
moment
c'est sain c'est dangereux ok maintenant
en échange
c'est chaud un boum c'était chaud
à
c'est bon vas-y francky c'est bon
vas-y francky c'est bon bon bon vas-y
francky c'est bon allez allez on a le
temps encore pour deux l'adoption est en
cours
d'optionnel progresse qu en anglais à
des anglais qui regardent la de
l'adoption à une progresse je couvre
quoi vous
a été prompt à f2 voyez dame français 5
qui sauf la chance la [ __ ] je suis mal
pandey
ce que c'est si grave
est ce que c'est si grave
c'est mal joué ça
c'est pas mal joué sa foi de salma sueur
commandes
allez une dernière annonce il laisse pas
faire la dernière pour aux non il n'est
ce pas faire l'adoption au nom honorant
adam kirill au nom kirill
non je suis désolé pour toi à une partie
de l'adoption tu arrêtes comme ça il est
où ton problème qu à la fin c'était
proche de faire adopter coiffe un jour
tu ne peux pas arrêter comme ça tu n'as
pas le droit c'est comme elle c'est
comme un téléchargement mais ça tu sais
ça me fait penser à la mise à jour
windows telata la mise à jour tu es sur
l'écran tel petit cercle qui tourne et
puis ça n'avance pas à quoi tu étais tu
es là tu es à la feinte à 95% s'est
arrêté à amine tv qui lui c'est une
adoption quand même mais je pense c'est
plus qu'une adoption c'est une
humiliation ce que le mec a carrément un
mec a carrément a carrément raté ta
[ __ ] tu te rends 9 their assez
énervant c'est insupportable c'est
insupportable si près du but
si près du but c'est très décevant
je suis très déçu on était on est à sa
de l'adoption quoi il en restait une
allumette re voir un peu regardé son
profil qui rythma larves qu'est ce que
c'est que ça on n'a fait que neuf
parties conclut il ya que 9,0 en fait je
suis je m'étais dit s'il y avait une
partie jouée qu'il y avait eu 1 0
quelque part mais n'avait pas le droit
d'arrêter à ce moment là il n'avait pas
le droit d'arrêter ça devrait être
interdit ça ça devrait être interdit
j'avais un peu serré le jeu en plus pour
l'adopter
j'avais commencé par une pls et j'avais
serrer le jeu pour l'adoption assez
décevant
rachida rage suis super d'aig
j'avais tellement envie de l'adopter il
est resté au ris parce que je peux je
peux je peux pas me désinscrire de
l'aréna je vais te manger jouer la
première partie mais bon je veux pas
perdre 20 points dans une partie donc
c'est bon je garderai le lot à 2005
suffisant
c'est tellement écoeurant de rater
l'adoption là dessus quand même sympa tu
la rate même pas parce que tu perds une
particule tu fais une nulle tu la rade
parce que le mec se barre c'est ce qu'il
ya de pire
j'ai pas à gueuler dans le chat quand il
dit quelque chose quoi oui tu méritais
de l'adopter
non il n'avait pas le droit de faire ça
il avait pas le droit sérieux c'est à ça
à ce à quoi bon aller on a le tournoi
bon alors là rien avoué il a joué moi je
voulais qu une partie j'essaie de me
barrer de l'aréna si je peux je serai
pas prochaines parties en fait
ouais ça se comprend qu'après neuf il
soit parti boom cristal qui abandonne
merci cris talent donc un bain il a
raison en fait c'est bien joué pour pour
l'aréna donc vous pouvez vous inscrire
afin d'être inscrit au club lead stream
c'est des gens qui ne savent pas comment
faire
écrivez moi je veux un peu suivre des
parties on va suivre amine justement qui
nous parlaient d'adoption tard l'instant
je vais voir un peu d'ogm ce qui fait
super chaud en ce moment il faut
s'hydrater les mais qu'il faut
s'hydrater
qu'est ce que c'est que cette partie as
tu n'as lapine enseigna lapine bizarre
charente sur ces tranches plus tôt avec
des cinq pour profiter du fait qu'ils
aient plus qualifiés 3 pour chasser la
dame
bon j'ai un peu de chic et de chat quand
même histoire de voir céder des
inscriptions
c'est vrai qu'on a un vote pour savoir
si eux alors sous clans qui n'ont
commencé pour s'inscrire d'abord il faut
que tu sois est-ce que tu as inscrit au
club au club bitstream en fait c'est un
peu la question qu'on se pose pas rond
que je me pose en fait ce que je suis
salins donc automatiquement je me pose
des questions à moi même déjà il faut il
faut que je participe au club lead
stream qui est ici après faut que tu
ailles dans les tournois en cours dans
la section live duchess comme et tu
pourras tu pourras participer mais la
amy tu penses faut qu'ils réussissent
ils réagissent aux cent soit avec eux
cinq soit avec des cinq premières vues
je serai peut-être de faire 1 5 mètre
carré dans des cas c'est pas ou g6 fou
g7 et réagir plus tard mais aussi selon
c'est forcément pas bon ok a eu 5 mai
truc sic sur des 5 qu'est ce qu'on fait
mon envoi lecavalier en des cats ont
fait qu on fait ça ça ça ça j'ai si ça
et ça mais bon il y avait cassé 6 pour
le cavale et j'ai l'impression que le
fou va pas trop parler
donc le club literie g20 que les liens
de partout annoncé ta douche avait fait
vraiment l'effort quand j'ai dû gagner
13 parties d'affilée là aujourd'hui
j'avais vraiment fait un bel effort faut
que cinq à avoir est ce qu'on fait des
cinq essais sur des cinq fait cavalier e
set c'est quand même un peu triste quoi
bon il envoie le pion mais je pense vous
prend et cava lieu de mai peut-être
peut-être dameuse
moi j'y crois pas mais peut-être leur
prise prises qui avait lieu de peut-être
dame e7 en premier on s'en prend à ce à
quoi que là il ya peut-être juste prise
prises et rock et ça va être chiant
peut-être qu avait lieu de on bouffe là
et on fait j'ai six arrêts ça peut
peut-être aller on met le fond g7
du coup je pense on bouffe f3 et ont
fait g6 non mais ça va peut-être pour
les noirs juste mais ça va mais j'ai six
fours g7 et puisque le truc c'est que si
les blancs fonroque ce qui va se passer
un jour c'est qu'il va y avoir cavaliers
h 5 fu g7 fou aux cinq d'un mach 4 et ça
va être chiant voilà je pensais juste
tranquillou fou j'ai cette cavale et h5
est donc un voyage sans que damages qu'à
ta question en fait c'est ce que fout g7
cavaliers sait si c'est chiant mais bon
je pense juste dame 17 ans viendra par
là au pire mais sinon on peut aussi
décider de commencer par coeur et le h5
pour rapidement ramené la dame en h4 et
at on dit c'est pas si grave de garder
le roi au centre un coup de plus je sais
pas honnêtement je sais pas
bon voyage historique m pas après le
souvenir en f4 mais j'aurais pas me le
font injustice perso probablement
restait très bon aussi 1,5 et des cartes
c'était pas mal joué avec fu pro f 3
dont qaïs et six bien joué aussi je mets
un truc comme dan 17 mai c'est vraiment
problématique en fait tout ça le ferait
il est bloqué derrière les pions et le
fou noir au contraire ils parlent sur
les cases noires devant les pions c'est
un problème mais bon dames 17
j'ai parce qu'on fait du roi blanc en
fait
on va pas réussir un truc d'harmonie
pour les blancs ici
ce qu'on réussit pas le truc c'est que
si le roi vient ici va se prendre les
chèques désagréable en f4 il aura pas
trop de cases ou alors on monte en g3
mais bon
mais bon ca spatiale ces cavaliers h5
avaler f4
les noirs sont très bien très difficile
de se dépêtrer de ce truc là avec les
blancs
problème c'est vraiment le roi en fait
vraiment pas de cazaril essaye de
s'activer am dam il a probablement
raison
on a mis les noirs vont avoir intérêt à
remettre leurs fous en g7 l'a déjà fou
g7 c'est chiant si jamais le fonds
arrive en c3 c'est quasi matt 9,5 aussi
possible pour ouvrir la colonne très
bien joué les blancs sont sacrément
malin el afou g7 le coup qui tue
enfilade et sur dame des impôts et c est
quand même de colmater ya poussé trois
pour qu'on est obligé de faire cinq là
mais bon il va y avoir plus on prend 1,5
cavalli prend 2,5 fou prend 1,5 à yassa
encore mais bon voilà puis on prend 1,4
intermédiaires et qu'on aura le temps de
bouger la tour mais je serais pas allé
vous fait la tour à faire ce genre est
pris en tout cas j'aurais continué
ouvrir les lignes
parce que si sauver la tour ça
permettait de faire f
ef et d'être collé une tour en 1 8 mais
bon les blancs rien de toute façon un
truc c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire dame
prendre ce cas tours 8
et qu'il n'y a pas de bonnes cases pour
la dame tête vous faire d'alger 4 parce
qu'après dame frange rica tfg à ces
perdants il y avait prend et ça va être
horrible mais peut-être que la finale
c'est quand même le mieux pour essayer
de tenir moi j'aurais fait dame g4
d'amérique at on essaye de fouiner
badham g5 j'aime pas puis on prend et on
essaie de freiner avec h5 pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas il fouine quand même nom
mais il faut il quand même nom mais ce
que j'aime bien c'est que sur ta meuf 5
la cave a lieu sept et des trucs comme
ça allait h5 ne sait pas en voie de
façon maintenant tour 8,3 d1t serein
quoi peut-être fait fou des trois tours
8,3 en f1 tu souffles fois du cache ton
roi et tu prépares un truc c'est que
j'ai très envie de tenter le piège des
rêves 5/4 hélios est quand même ouf h3
peut-être pas peut-être pu faire foi je
crois pour aller de coller
le truc c'est qu'il ya dame f5 et sur
qui a valu au set pour prendre cette
dame prend 1,7 j'imagine qu'avec dame b
un échec ça va faire mal
et du coup on aurait peut-être pu faire
flasher 3 es fou aussi ça s'arrêtait pas
mal ça la fois h trois échecs bon et
surtout rui 3 fm on touche à rien et
dames cette fois aussi tu as fou et on
essaye de se placer ça aurait été pas
mal voilà c'est vraiment dommage que
carew cette marche pas parce que
normalement on va se faire mater comme
des merdes mais parce qu'on est obligé
d'avancer de la peut pas l'enlever ya
poussé trois matches et quand on va
là-bas ya la tour qui rentre t dmb de
maths c'est pas de chance que c'était là
le piège qu'on avait envie de tenter
mais pour ça que des fourrages 3 fallait
faire autre chose en fait du coup
aminchi a gagné alors medic un problème
de cadrage ah ouais ouais c'est vrai
qu'un problème de cadrage désolé mec si
parfois ça des cadres et mais depuis le
début un problème de cadrage vous c'est
arrivé maintenant et vous m'avez pas dit
vous voyez quand même la colonne h mais
c'est moi qui ai toujours la fenêtre
sans faire exprès et personne ne
prévient je sais pas je viens d'arriver
je sais pas ça
je pense que ça a dû arriver après en
fait on peut aussi le dire ok bah il
aurait fallu quand même comment ça ce
qui l'a peut être inscrit au club
bitstream pourra prévoir s'inscrire sur
le live
non mais c'était ça arrive et après ça
arrivait après n'ai pas trop eu de
cadrage avant donc on est bon
je regardais l'autre chat qu'on était
vraiment temps imparti souvient grille
je trouve toujours pas c'est un aréna
king est ce que tu t'es donc tu t'es
inscrit au club est allé dans czech
comme slash live battu doit le trouver
dans le tournoi ça s'appelle l'aréna des
tontons et on est 22 pour le moment
salut à buck
donc vous voyez une partie entre eux et
l'or le plus fort contre njn 75017 am
vienne 1900 15h17 c'est le mec c'est son
code postal qu'il représente et au
classement de l'aréna on verra on verra
plus tard
du coup c'est un genre de stonewall qui
ont 6 pas forcément je me demandais ce
que je peux faire prise prise est prise
en fait d'un prend fous ces cas tu vois
et surpris si prend là je prends la
moquée qui a aidé 5 et après je vois est
ce que je prends ou pas je suis même pas
sur scène j'ai pas envie de prendre pour
pas l'activer peut-être fait juste fou
d2 puis on l'a et tour c'est un camp et
je vis à voir mais on veut quand même
très envie de faire pris ce risque qu'il
prend
mais je trouve pas le soin de ce soir le
2 mai 2008 18 20 banon mais s'il a
transcrit au club et que vous allez dans
chaise comme live vous devez trouver et
après vous allez là une fois que vous
êtes inscrit au club vous allez là et
vous allez trouver
alors attendez qu est ce qui se passe à
oui parce que j'ai cliqué j'ai fait de
chasse comme live voilà c'est pour ça ok
donc il a fait ça il faut aussi souk est
donc la tactique qui faisait plaisent
tapie tati qui fait plaise
du coup
je remets le lien après dans pour le
chase comme live
non je sais pas mais on assure toujours
des problèmes pour trouver ces tournois
je sais pas ce fait plus d'un an qu'on
les fait tous les mois tous les mois
tous les mois et des difficultés à
trouver ça doit pas être si simple en
moi j'ai trouvé du premier coup perso
mais bon je comprends la logique de
chaises comme on l'attend on sent le cat
way mais je pense que plutôt joué avec
les pros f7 pour apprend f7 dame b3 et
là il va faire foufou c4 et il va les
prendre la call of ways quatre jours de
stream d'affilée d'ailleurs n'oubliez
pas que lundi lundi 19h15 on aura sur
youtube 1
un live pédagogique si pour ceux qui ont
vu le calendrier sur facebook et on
enchaînera avec l'arena king bullet sera
pas forcément évident de jouer mais bon
comme disais je il ya eu beaucoup
d'arena beaucoup de deux gros tournois
dont pour la jouer en toute détente est
à noter que mardi prochain à 22h on
tentera de se qualifier pour le speech à
ce n'est ni vais pas vous abonner aussi
à la chaîne chaise comme fr / twitch de
la suivre en tout cas
alors là ngn 75017 qui est quand même
très mal il a quoi il a il a quatre
pions contre 3 4 5 6 7 et quoi ton futur
alors à changer de parti y en avoir deux
à quatre ils vont cinq miss clic mais
bon rien à voir quoi il y en a marre de
cette partie on va aller voir on va
aller voir on va aller voir quoi
alors alors sous collin qui a finalement
réussi à s'inscrire donc du coup cette
envie d'aller le voir et joue contre
kiel rhein 24 qui nous vient de belgique
et qui demain jour à un gros kieran
demain qui joue un gros quart de finale
de coupe du monde contre contre le
brésil demain soir 20h attention qu'il
aran n'est ce que tu as intérêt à jouer
ce tournoi est pas allé te préparer pour
la coupe du monde ou est ce que tu va
rater le match ne sera pas titulaire
peut-être là ça fait penser un peu aux
structures de pions type française et
blanc adore et avoir un fou de cases
blanches mais ils n'ont pas et du coup
les noirs vous quand même réussir à
s'activer j'aime bien les noirs ici
jean luc est adapté de venir e4 ça peut
aller pour les noirs ici ça peut aller
pour les noirs et la reine qui rigole
dans le chatt ouais mais c'est pas drôle
qui leur âne c'est pas c'est pas drôle
si l'équipe de belgique se fait éliminer
à cause de toi c'est pas très marrant
qui est en train de tout remettre en
cause pour son pays il va peut-être se
prendre du cavaly détroit ça va lui
faire les pieds qui est des trois salles
faire chier parce que où va la tour tour
elf inquiets français un d'un point est
fin et on gagne une calloc'h tour 2 qui
avait français en russie et c'est une
jeune ilan y avait problème de l'échec
cavalière de l'échec fourchette annoncée
kiel rhein qui est en train de le faire
au [ __ ] killoran qu'est en train de
représenter la belgique
attention je raconte de la merde qu'il
raconte est en train de gagner cette
partie d'échecs mais tout le peuple
belge s'en fout parce qu'il ne pense
qu'au match de foot de demain une partie
qui n'est pas très médiatisé
est-ce qui va voir cavaliers français 1
dames france dames prend enfin pas si
facile à voir parce qu'on prend avec la
dame en premier c'est de la petite
tactique du dimanche
il peut la rate et il peut la rater mais
ça se peut qu'ils écoutent le stream et
donc qu'ils la voient donc il est
entendu
bah je voulais un style entendu tu l'as
entendu un édit qu'on le déconcentre on
lui donne les coups [ __ ] les mecs as
que sur qu'elle prendrait des crs que s
composé des souks où l'un alors et s'est
trouvé un truc pour ce coup là un truc
de fou et on va aider tout le monde dans
cette partie non mais bon qu'est
français un d'un français d'un point f1
prise prise prise bon il va falloir qu
ils arnaquent cette finale sous coup là
il ya quand même 600 points d'eau de
plus irene qui a fait semblant de
réfléchir même s'il a attendu deux
entendus depuis plus d'une minute sur le
stream la combinaison gagnante mais en
train de faire style je les trouvais
moi-même
ouais c'est fourbe c'est beau est ce
qu'ils vont encore réfléchir pour dame
prenait fin en ça y est il y va il y va
mais l'aurait alors est-ce que sous
coulin avec six ans pour lots de plus
fou c'est là c'est comme si le contraire
1900 jeu l'arnacoeur déjà montré hier
contre les arnaques ça la carène qui
chutent attention il pense qu'on n'a pas
compris son jeu on va plus donné de
coups ou alors on va lui donner des
coups de merde exprès pour le point lui
pour le pour le piéger attention de pas
forcément écouté ce qu'on va dire
maintenant qu'il ran tu va craquer qu'il
ran tu va la perdre
attention à il fait de la merde békaa de
faire le jeu et ce qui va à merde il a
vu le bon coup à cinq c'est bien joué
perry qui tombent dans le panneau
il fout pas mal qu'il ran
allez succo la sauve là
tu va craquer qu'il rate tu va craquer
tonton
alors attention allez on se défend aller
sous call un f5 envoie c'est trop
protecteur faut aller l'attaquer folle
agressé il faut le tacler [ __ ] tu vas
te faire échanger les tours de toute
façon attendait 1 c'est une perte de
temps fallu faire peur f5 à attaquer
envoyé on s'en fout les 5 bis si ça les
fait le cracker à bouffe du cavale fou à
putte un fou faire une incertitude à les
boubous froid j'ai deux allées on monte
car à dieu de roy f3 on tient tout il va
faire pour ses seins qui a valu aux deux
tours ces deux rois f3 froid 2 3 et puis
on monte à l'est après tu envoies le
pion b et tu te bats adf peut-être tu
passes 3f de roisin roi roi des huns
peut-être faut mieux l'attaquer par en
dessous
parce qu'en fait je vois pas comment tu
vas chasser la tour la serbe est chiant
bon allez pouces f6 voilà c'est bien
joué et espère que vale tu pousses h4 et
envoie ton pions b un petit peu tu fais
déjà b st gall et h4 on bloque tout en
fait tu commences par h4 mais bon c'est
pas grave
trafic en tous cas et des casse têtes on
prend h2 [ __ ] fait chier a dû qu'on
pourra pas faire cavalier e 2 pour
bloquer voilà ashkan ashkan ashkan allez
on pousse on sauve le pion
ce coup là il est mal à ce coup là il
est dans la merde là sous couleur il pas
le plus haut du jour de l'an merci au
chat est dans la merde [ __ ] allait
aussi souk où l'un de six étaient
obligés à léo 6 d'obliger au moins tu
auras roi g4 et tu pourras faire quelque
chose conclure éventuellement cas ici
c'est vicieux mais le truc c'est que la
juste faire rage 6 bon il va te faire
plus on prend un bon bref ce à quoi il
joue bien avec il râle un délicieux mais
c'est trop téléphonée
c'était trop téléphonée
turan qui va la gagner qui a fait une
belle partie c'était trop téléphonée
quoi à l'été france et 4 qu'elle prend
b2 à [ __ ] comptera une dame de moins
bons à l'espace et en corse pas fait sur
un français kad b6 allez tu le fais
tomber à l'ebbe 6 3 p 5
ces cinq hariri roi c4 vient ce procès
ça il défend mal avec les noirs les
baies 5b cette [ __ ] tu pourras pas
pouvoir marquer c'est cet échec sirois 8
il a vu à assez horrible fallait
commencer par bessette pour faire c'est
cet échec
ça c'est dommage
c'est dommage genre là s'il avait
commencé par bessette ça il aurait pu
faire c'est cet échec est quand même
tout repenser cette salle est toujours
là mais bon au moins ils avaient plus
d'échecs avec accueil en avec un [ __ ]
a assez triste
allez roi geslin tempo on espère à il se
plante il fait pas d'âme deux allées roi
de halle et tu vas faire un nul
bref un prêt nous ré fairway f1 bien
joué 3 g 2o h 2 3h de il sait pas
matelly s'est pas mater avec un roi une
dame et le pat il savait pas mat avec 3
et dames
tu t'en tires bien trop collant tu t'en
tires bien ça c'est beau on va des
partis comme ça je dis c'est de l'art à
ce niveau là c'est plus des échecs
ils savaient pas ma taille trois dames
alors on y tombe direct et une victoire
de la guide
on va revoir à mine un peu ce que ça
donne il ya en cave qui a stressé
la ministre fait pas n'importe quoi et à
faire d'anne frank si ce sujet cinq
échecs il va mater en force
je crois juste par un problème au fait
tu fais juste trois champs et à rien
mais il réfléchit trop amin au pire il
fait d'armes français cette épreuve 6
mathieu roy chant et puis c'est bon
enfin y'a rien quoi les foules et 5 fu
cette dame prend la fuite
c'est ça la force est encore alors si tu
es fou g5 fuglseth d'alain fuite mat
allez tout reprendre cette foulée 5
aïe aïe aïe c'est trop matérialiste où
ça allait tout reprend 1,7
ils méritent de la perdre non ça
soufflera pas loin de tomber comme ça tu
prêt move dans ces cas-là tonton rouabeh
hui trois sets tu vas tu me fais deux
petits prés move des familles roy baby
3,7 et tu fais tomber
aïe aïe aïe allez on va aller voir
emmanuel guignard qui est quand même
bien parce qu'il est noir
aïe aïe aïe aïe à rien
des finales séduire un aller mais là on
joue quand même plus vite manu tu as une
pièce de plus à l'état pâtit confie à
gagner la cadence et du 5 0
ma nuit ici tu réfléchis trop là il va
je sais pas c'est foutu sent qu'il ya un
souci pour man u
il ya un truc qui chagrine clairement
n'a pas envie de se prendre des tours
sur la 7e ou quoi mais faut quand même
jouer plus vite ça craint pas les temps
sur la 7e
enfin un peu gaffe option mais bon c'est
que des fois quand tu joues lentement
comme ça tu perds un peu le le flot de
la partie allait b6 trucks et passent
des fois quand tu joues en compte le
faire moi je perds un peu le flou
parfois quand j'hésite sur les positions
gagnantes
c'est en tout cas l'air facile au début
il faille mais des trucs à faire échec
des machins jouer vite bouger les pièces
et là tout d'un coup froid b5 je sais
pas assez s'il a perdu le flot de la
partie il est en train de complètement
désorganisée ses tours il se met dans le
caca tout seul en fait surtout tour ces
cinq là il ne sait pas ce qui l'a foutu
et d'y jouer la plus de temps at war
huit échecs c'est pas très bien joué ce
père me roy de monter mais bon il doit
le voir jouer autant le jour avec les
blancs il a mieux fait de faire tourner
et indirect puisqu'il aurait des chances
de tour des huit matchs les manu il faut
jouer plus vite là tu prends trop ton
temps cavaliers le système peau hâlée
allez faut près move l'a4 à l'est près
mon frérot qui a valu à 5,5 très mou
voilà c'est bien mais maintenant trois
pré move aller eux 2-1 mais bon tu auras
pas de temps tu as perdu ta tête tu es
trop lentement savez la position
gagnante fallait tabler le flou tomber
de ma main était complètement gagnante a
réussi à s'en sortir mais tu as tu as
été trop longs moments importants tu as
trop pris ton temps dans la position
complètement gagnant ne fallait juste
faire un peu tourner les coûts et puis
ce serait des merdes et après quoi
ah les alouettes baba finale technique
petite finale technique
alors qu'ils la jouent pas mal au final
et bien la remontée le roi envoyé le roi
réussissait tout rose pas ouais
pas sûr que cela suffise
pascal roy g5 qui remonte et 3g sain il
faut jouer actifs là qu'est ce que c'est
que ce roi g7 noches ou vallée faut
activer ces pièces en finale
c'est dommage de pourrir c'est parti sur
des erreurs techniques faciles comme ça
c'est le grand show là cette technique
en finale c'est le gange alentours des 2
ça va c'est ça a quand même gagné mais
s'active et c'est important
ouais mais tu vas tomber mais mais tu
mérites de tomber en fait désolé désolé
pour nos chefs tu méritais de tomber on
est cruel alors avoir aladin sans voix
alors comme on peut jouer on lui demanda
déjà foutu et inscrivent sur le club
liste rim après que tu ailles dans le
dans la section live paquito finement
est ce que tu sais commentaires seraient
sur le stream sur le club by stream
klabi stream germes est l'adresse de
partout pour tout le monde
histoire qu'on est l'adresse partout
allez on se bat allez on fait rock
aladin aladin qui n'a pas de voix aladin
qui est aphone aller bouffe avec le
cavaliere et aladdin baladins avec
lecavalier et puis tu viens tournicoter
de ce côté là tu fais tes prend à 4
installe donc et on sait qu as tu te
bats quoi
allez à la la
voilà dans
alors comment escalade un peu faire faux
qui mène une attaque sur l'oral à de
façon aladin qu'est-ce qui peut aller
fouiner d'un petit aladin qui alla d'un
san mamés saladin von sayn je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai appelé alain sans voix
c'est la lecture automatique
mais bon on enchaîne on enchaîne ce tour
c'est cet aller-retour c7 à la halle et
aladin allez on suit le chat on fait
tourner cette page 4 tu as tout reprend
ses 8 francs bessette peut-être
est-ce que tu envoies ans et 8 es fou
prend 17 quand même bakiev saint quentin
l'epic fail d'aladin
aïe aïe aïe
ah le fou qui tombe
affreux
on va changer de parti c'est trop
frustrant d'avoir raté on va voir à
nîmes contre creed altair c'est
intéressant et amine qui va battre
[ __ ] bien joué à mine alors qu'est ce
qu'on en leader on à tchekhov
j'ai regardé kaiser sozé contre crystal
ça est intéressant car il ya des
problèmes de connexion ainsi tu peux
expliquer sa défaite contre amine et qui
abandonnent un problème de connexion
mais c'est de retrouver kaiser et ses
deux recrues kaiser dans le tournoi ah
bah justement ils jouent contre tchekhov
qui est leader c4c si ce teaser qui me
copier un petit peu sévère voire vote
ont célébré échec
il reste 22 minutes dans le tournoi tout
est encore possible vendre des changes
delà de la slave de 3,3 pas terrible de
3 patrie puisque sa garde le fou cacher
même envie de dire chez k et oui nous
parlons verlan ici même à l'exercice
foot c'est horrible cette paire de jouer
des blancs là après ça s'est passé pas
dramatique à l'imposition va pas être ça
doit pas être graves
mais bon juste philosophiquement tuant
ferme ça ben ok je te faire aussi soudé
6 rock et partir un peu comme si tu
avais les noirs quoi j'essayais soudé si
c'est toute la bonne compagnie
compliqué pour tchekhov ou là en plus
prendre là à ce moment là c'est hyper
mauvais parce que du coup on ouvre la
colonne trop tôt tchekhov qui vont
vraiment mal cette position
là il a peut-être le temps de faire un
petit damas quatre échecs au passage je
sens très bien dans ma cave quand même
assez logique de profiter du roi qui
reste et qui reste est mal placé kébé 5
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas
peut-être car il ya eu 5 c'est un peu
tôt
c'est à dire qui c'est quatre quand même
et ses bouffées le fou
ils attendaient ce que est ce que je la
glace et peut-être twitch qui lag un
truc qu'il ait c'est possible baby très
bon peut-être fou b4 et accueille ses
quatre marques
ça va aller mais un truc un peu
artificielle tam un 4b calisesi sur
brock peut-être maroc s'est pas aussi
bien les filles ont prises mais rsa doit
non ça va aller ça allait quand même ça
va aller je vais allumer la lumière la
nuit est en train de tomber je peux vous
dire qu'il fait super chaud il fait
vraiment super chaud c'est une horreur
il ya un petit os rafter avec de la
pluie je pensais que ça allait aller
faire refroidir mais ça n'a pas duré
très longtemps
non
c'est pas mal tout ça tout ça pour les
noirs damage deux échecs d'un machin ça
va rentrer l'épaulement ça tient
ce vaincu valant le 2 je me demande
comment on est autour des 8 mai et
menacé tout reprendre et 4 quoi mais
c'est juste fou c3 et après ce qu'aime
superbe choix position blanche et super
moche
peut-être que faire b5 avec les blancs
genre b5 c'est peut-être pas mal tapions
prend est prise
et le tour prend des cadres dont je vous
parlais avec qui on prend qui les prend
des 4l en faisant la dame est mal blasé
steppa matin sinon mais sa santé que ça
commence à menacer mais il coupait 5
c'était pas mal pour [ __ ] un peu le
bordel
ouais
c'est pas terrible il peut y avoir une
idée de fouine mercure pouvait utiliser
de fouine s'arrêter de faire d'alger 3d
c'est d'enfermer la dame via cavalli ces
deux le truc c'est que le fouloir uni en
belgique et là me prend d un étranger
cinq catastrophes catastrophe donc lé
dossier qui remonte dans le tournoi
alors allez regarder manuel guynemer
contre imad ac - lattes façon ils feront
f1 au et damages croit tous et en maths
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe manu guinard qui va
perdre contre imad hakim addad qui aura
sorti une grosse partie d'ataxie voix
dame h3c gagné 6 voix damage pas tous
français gagnera il le foie il le voit
il le voit est difficile pour man u
difficile pour man u man u qui perd
qu'est ce qu'on allait voir
peut-être cristal contre tchekhov c'est
une partie doit être importante pour la
gagne on va donc revoir tchekhov mal et
on le revoit par son chef une partie le
début en plus quitte à la qui va
attaquer violemment
bon chez kafia mon avis doit tenter de
faire style qu'il n'y a pas de grosses
menaces parce que ça me semble difficile
pour tchekhov de de défendre son roi le
monde à mach 6 kg 5 ça arrive vite quand
même
c'est quand même bien de la merde je
pense on a essayé de tenter un truc avec
dan des 5 ou quoi mais bon parler il va
se faire mater quoi enfin c'est de la
merde total
3-5 tour la balle est en crise et qatari
tu as de prendre tout retour ici tu vas
te faire un look et me faire arrêter
comme une merde quoi heureusement il ne
fait pas donc mais là c'est horrible
j'ai parfois conseillé aux noirs là
c'est son rôle s'est fait attaquer trop
vite
donc il est ce là pour prendre six d'un
point f de la justice a abandonné
donc voilà du coup amine premier alors
on va aller voir la mine qui est leader
du tournoi et qui joue contre un autre
joueur marocain imad ac
la mine qui est bien non ou pas je les
confonds en fait ce qu'ils ont les deux
il ya minima dit long et 2 les drapeaux
marocains peut-être c'est imad qui est
bien là au contraire
genre à me demander ce qui se passe sur
damien mais elle faisait 4 c'est un vrai
problème
amin qui a peut-être perdu 6 ha minh tu
perds ça veut dire qu'il ya là guy tu
écris talent qui reviennent parce qu'ils
ont le strict
il reste que 12 minutes dans le tournoi
je conseille quand c'est toi le streak
est important donc
pour amy il faut vraiment absolument
gagner mais il m'a d'acs qui l'a
mystifié et là il réfléchit trop
longtemps en plus faut se décider pour
quelque chose
d'immatriculation à les prendre en d1
et ça reste pas si simple
c'est risqué
c'est très risqué
je sais pas comment ça va se terminer
cette histoire mais allait bien les fous
qui sont braqués dans prend b2 tes
couilles
c'est vrai que l' avantage de la dame
qui attaquent le carré lisse et que ça
évite les trucs de type vous prend de
vous prendre tout reprend ce qu'il ya de
france et 3 entre temps après peut-être
que les blancs rythme il aurait pu te
faire ou là désolé j'ai mis ce clic
mais je me demande en fait s'il pouvait
pas faire un truc de grosses fouine
c'est de faire tout reprend prise prise
prise est là et peut-être rien parce
qu'elles émanent du couloir un homme
c'est bien je vous en fait d'un prend b2
je pense genre de coups de défense
un truc avec ton problème si ça marchait
pas causer mat du couloir mais sinon ça
aurait été une idée assez violente je
regarde juste au classement à l'hélice
effet dépassé en fait ici père amine là
il aura plus le strict il se sera fait
raser la mine s'ils perdent c'est fini
peut plus gagner le tour et s'il fait
nul non plus d'ailleurs je pense
jouets carrieu 4
si ouver'thur 8 km le cas tu es fou des
huit pas toujours trop trop moto avec
les pièces comme salarié peut leur fout
des six mais bon je sais pas je sais pas
j'ai l'impression que c'est vrai c'est
pas évident beaucoup de pièces blanches
qui sont braqués sur le roi pas évident
à défendre
j'ai un petit truc de déconnexion je met
un petit refresh pour vérifier que tout
aille bien
pas évident
quelles idées profondes sur cavaillon
e42 défense 4 bon après c'est pas la fin
du monde
on peut aussi faire prise prises et f 5
c'est pas la fin du monde mais là pour
les gamines joue beaucoup plus vite en
fait dam des deux alors c'est quoi
l'idée profond de dames d2
parce que quelque part il s'auto cloud
tu as tu envie de faire un truc comme
damas cinq maintenant histoire de clouer
là et d'attaquer sa avec l'idée sur dame
e3 de faire piéger 4 mai ojeda me 4
encore l'abaisser quant à tant de pièces
braqués sur ton roi s'est jamais simple
il ya toujours des trucs à
du coup d'un me 3 c'est jouable
kg 4 dames 1 4 mais c'est compliqué à
jouer pour les noirs convoqué il a pris
officie ce prix a mis six heures ça je
comprends pas trop ok mais le truc c'est
que tu auras pas le temps de prendre six
puisqu'il ya dames 1 donc là si les
noirs prennent d'ailleurs à jamais dame
prend 1,6 madame un bail aie aie
après faut le voir un gamin va pas le
voir madame c'est un aller il m'a dit
qu'il va perdre autant quoi pas les
dames français de la courgerie tempo
mais pas joué assez vite à il lui manque
de couilles et mon tour b 8 tours b 1 a
du coup amin qui reste en course pour la
gagne dans le tournoi mais qui a mis
beaucoup de temps à gagner donc
également distancée par crypte talent
donc on peut aller voir crypte talent
parce que je suis toujours les coups de
canon peut-être qu'ils écoutent je ne
sais pas mais bon faut vu qu'il arrêtait
d'armer un matin et qui la vieille dame
prend ainsi soin je suis pas sûr selon
la partie d'avant là quand même si les
mecs écoute et ils sont quand même les
saints mater en 1 et d'un autre côté ça
va parler pour les deux joueurs donc
pendant cristal qui va gagner le tournoi
très tranquillement il a fait un gros
run alors pour la deuxième place à jour
ce check off et amine où la guitare la
guide on l'a pas trop vu et la guide qui
peut faire une remontée forêt qui
gagnent rapidement alors il est où il
habite
il est là la gitl à gits il a besoin de
gagner à tout prix et ils jouent contre
eux et l'or le plus fort c'est quoi ce
fait il y aurait peut-être mieux fait de
prendre avec le roi mais bon quand j'ai
quatre là
en 86 à la chance roi des deux bien joué
donc la guide qui va gagner et la
guitare y va se retrouver ou dans le
tournoi il va se retrouver troisième
mais ça pour gagner je pense qu'il y
avait très facilement des rois des cinq
dames des six tours matt gilroy monte
échec en g7 allait taxer tous rue donc
la liste voyage deuxième c'est à dire
que amine ouais alors attendez wah wah
retourner voir la mine du coup peut-être
aura un peu kaiser sozé contre tchekhov
est ce que c'est important
tchekhov qui aurait bien prendre une
nulle matériellement on est ou 2 3 6 1
pour deux mois ça se tenir cette finale
de dame quand même cette dame f5 et s
qui a des perpète ou pas sur ta meuf 5
je pense qu'il ya dame pro f 6 et ça
évite les perpète parce que le droit
pour venir se cache en h2 et sur d'amd à
dammaj s'inclura d'un match 4,60 obligé
de faire dame f5 donc autant faire des
rêves 5 tempo
mais aussi d'apprendre et 5 de mahler
jouable bon c'est très naïve se faire
sans dane d'un échec très bien joué de
la part de tchekhov très très mal joué
voilà finale d'options j'ai peu de doute
parce que truc c'est qu'il ya deux 4,5
contre 2 4 6 et un pion de mois et 3,5
roy croit ces cinq les machins et
barrois c5 ou g4 ça ça gagne aussi ouais
alors ce que peut faire tchekhov mais
j'ai passé un temps intéressé je vais la
montre là puisque deux minutes trente il
peut empêcher kaiser de marquer des
points mais c'est pas forcément son
intérêt il a vraiment besoin de marquer
donc chekhov
alors du coup ils centrent la gaieté
amine que ça se joue alors je pense
c'est plutôt amin qui peut remonter
amine s'ils gagnent ils remontent sur le
podium mais il a plus beaucoup de temps
alors on va voir il en est où amis il
est où il joue contre manu guignard
ouais ça va être dur après il est
gagnant avec les noirs avec les blancs
pardon
ils ont messi se passer macha et ses
gagnants mais pas faire toi mais bon le
truc c'est que c'est dur à gagner il ya
une minute dix y gagnera pas donc amin
qui aura été éjecté du podium donc ça
reste sûrement faire un cryptage premier
par la guide façon il a commencé la
partie à peu de temps tchekhov deuxième
les dommages pour à minsk il a fait 7
sur 7 il a tout gagné
mais pas assez vite
pas assez brutal
dès 5 ans mais manu qui joue bien
résout seconde personne gagnera et donc
ça va faire que tal tchekhov la gitl à
git
à moins que la guide gagne là dans les
quelques secondes qui viennent ou qu'il
fasse nul s'ils proposent nul la guide
qui peut raser
non ils rasent rappaz est donc ça fait
crypte alain tchekhov de la guide 3
amine quat'sous coulin qui finit 5e
kaiser sozé je fais cinq sur cinq fait
5e aussi il arrivé un peu en retard donc
beau tournoi les mecs un beau tournoi
vous serez battu à fond
et n'oubliez pas donc je vais vous je
vous m je vous met un petit lien là
encore parce que demain il ya un cadeau
à gagner il ya le tournoi qui va être le
tournoi hebdomadaire chess comme et qui
va
et dont le vainqueur va remporter enfin
remporter un abonnement un abonnement
d'un mois diamant donc je vous mets le
lien pour vous inscrire au club ce sera
demain soir à 20h30
je mettrai un petit message sur le club
donc ça voilà je mets le petit lien de
partout sur le club sport que vous
inscriviez donc pour évoluer de la même
manière que ce soir sauf que ce sera pas
commenter en direct et donc ça sera un
tournoi hebdomadaire sera tous les
vendredis 20h30 à la différence du
touron à vis rime qu'avec une fois par
mois pour moi j'espère que vous aurez
bien kiffé ce petit stream
dommage pour l'adoption en début de camp
des bus de retransmission enfin j'aurais
bien aimé l'adopter mais bon c'est comme
ça c'est comme ça on n'a pas réussi à
adopter on n'a pas réussi à adopter
enfin on n'y peut rien quoi le mec s'est
arrêté à 9,0 il s'est arrêté à 9,0 et
donc je vais vous laisser vous souhaite
à tous une super bonne soirée et bon
courage pour le match demain j'espère
que vous pourrez le regarder le petit
fond sur hugo et ben qui fait on se
retrouve lundi 19h15 pour le live
pédagogique suivi de l'aréna en bullet
turbo les mecs